jessica
st michelle of all that is
hello hello atlas
[Laughter]
round three round three three times a
charm
it is and what an evolution that we've
been through since
those first two yeah i was actually just
as we were about to start i was thinking
about how
i met you right after i was
in ecuador right after i had this huge
vision
of a divine feminine city two years ago
and i remember being so moved and yet so
distraught because i didn't know how to
create it
you know like you get the vision and
you're like oh my god i know that this
thing
is freaking amazing and i saw it was
like in the
design of the divine feminine in every
way
and i had no idea how that was going to
come into reality at all and i remember
sobbing as i was getting the download
during a
san pedro journey and i was like i don't
know how to build this
i have no idea how to build this all i
know how to do is channel that's all i
know how to do
and i left ecuador to go to a jason
silva event
to volunteer and you were running it and
that's how we met
and you know and so to be here two years
later and
you were the first knight
you know the first man that i brought
into the knighthood of the order of the
divine feminine
you know a couple of months later and
and that was our first journey
into rituals as a priestess and as a
channel and i mean these were things
that were just dropped in and we did it
and it was so profound and i remember
getting ready for
this ceremony that i want to do for you
and there was um
that that um that badge that that pen
the pen that had the rainbow colors on
it and i was at a retreat
of over a hundred women and i remember
going to each of them and being like
there's this man that wants to stand for
us
and support us and protect us and be
there for
us for the divine feminine
could you give him some love because of
what he's going to face
out there he's going to need a lot of
our
love and support for him and his efforts
and who he
is and how he wants to show up in this
world and so dozens and dozens of women
each held that piece and they were
transmitting
and infusing their love and their magic
and their appreciation for
you for how you were going to represent
all of us and stand and be one of our
brothers
and and then to do the ceremony with you
that like
i mean that was a whole channeled thing
and
so now like again two years later even
though i didn't have the thing
but i had the vision and i showed up and
you showed up and we both
did and how it's rippled out
to like come to this other
evolution revolution of the spiral two
years later is
incredible
so thank you
it's
it's as though the vision
that you had in ecuador
was
coming several years later
and that you went through the
foundational steps
that enabled it to become in motion
and there were my trials of fire
and initiation so like there was the all
right we're going to have just learned
how to channel and
step in as a shaman and oh let's go have
her learn to be a dominatrix and
oh let's have her study some temple art
and body
and like and and all these paths and i
was like why am i being guided down
these paths like none of these make
sense
and to see how it's synthesized together
yes
are you gonna say that yes and i would
actually like for you to
repeat all of the different fields
that you drew from one more time
yeah so i came from business so
business channeling so being a channel
and then i was guided to study plant
medicine and the shamanic path
and then i was guided to
step onto the dark path of the
dominatrix
and go into the dark there and
and then i was guided to learn about the
temple arts
of sensual body work of ritual or
ceremonies
of tantra you know these kinds of
components
while also becoming certified as a
sex coach and relationship coach like so
bringing
all those pieces together and i've
always been for
empowerment of women and then bringing
in
shadow work which takes empowerment to a
whole other level
this isn't business mindset okay
like we're gonna stand like wonder woman
that's like this is
channeling the the dominatrix energetics
and that's the thing that
i am now guiding women in
is getting them out of this feeling of
um being people pleasers and like i'll
do whatever
for love for safety for
for a living because that's how we had
to survive was
to do whatever it took giving our bodies
up
giving our souls up giving our hearts up
you know switching them out of
that to i do what pleases me to being
empowered what feels good to me what is
in my soul what is my truth where's my
courage and stepping into
what it is that i want and the
dominatrix is
a woman who knows who she is who knows
what she wants
and who knows what she stands for and
this is the time
for women to step out of just kind of
being
complacent and passive and or
a lot of women that have i mean so many
of us have experienced
the domination the power you know and
there's a lot of people who think that
the dominatrix is someone that has a
power over someone
that's not true in the truest form of
the dominatrix
it is an energetic where you're
unfuckable with
like you are in a total sovereign
authority of self
which is a huge huge shift so for me
to like come back now as like that that
dominatrix and that shaman piece
that i carry in when i work with women
and men but
particularly women and it's online and
we'll talk about the posse in a moment
but
the the power isn't going into our
shadows and we as women
we've been taught to wait for the white
night to come in oh you're
you're in trouble let's go rescue you
and put you on the back of my horse and
i'll ride you off into the sunset into
my kingdom
so now you're in their world and you
haven't dealt with your [ __ ]
because the white knight the light
masculine hasn't seen his own
dark so
so now it's like me helping women we're
not here to rescue
or enable each other but we're here to
go down into the darkness together yeah
go into our shadows and that's the
shaman path that's the dark
feminine path and it's divine yes
it's divine to do that works
you know how much i adore synthesis and
so
there were a lot of places to pull from
especially after receiving this vision
because
the north star appears in so many of our
lives
but the biggest question for us
when that north star appears is that
am i willing to go on the
strenuous journey in order for that
north star to be manifested
and it is a strenuous journey you had to
pull from a lot of different places
that enable you to have the synthesis
that you now carry and that you now
empower with
so this this very much so
this seems to be something that is
a in many ways a perennial
spiritual wisdom is that
the roots must reach
hell for the flowers to blossom towards
heaven
and that it's a place that
requires courage vulnerability
compassion patience healing
to enter and integrate and then to
resurface being much
wiser and courageous to achieve that
divine star and i really appreciate your
especially for for men this is something
that
is an important perspective because
when
when you have that story that you gave
a lot of the time it does feel like that
archetype of sort of
the the woman in a sense coming and
saying that i'm you know i'm in service
to that star and that i'm in service to
to to help and heal this and that
for some reason there seems to be some
sort of a
of a an arrow that
meets that as it comes inward in a sense
it then unlocks more and we we now live
in enough of a social fabric
that's robust enough that enables
the basic needs to be met at such a
level where there's more and more
potential and capacity for
women to step into a role that is more
sovereign
and that from there you can
have a more
a more truly integrated
being and a more truly
driven courageous being and actually men
would probably really actually
do really like that sovereignty
a lot like it seems to be like the next
evolutionist
for men that really like that
sovereignty in their partner rather than
that what seemed to be that archetype
that you painted earlier so it does seem
to be
the evolutionary trajectory that it's
moving in that direction and that it it
actually feels really right
that it it and by the way this is not to
say that like oh
you know traditional marriage you know
it com
it's traditional conservative values
disappear
and oh no no no no we're moving toward
the
liberalization and the in the
globalization
and there's all these sort of words and
worries and
it's almost like in a sense it's like
it's kind of like the archetype of the
of those that were concerned about the
motor vehicle
coming past the horse and
that this is not something to fear
this is something to embody because it's
actually going to be much better for
everybody
together and that
i think there's nothing more beautiful
than the gifts also being actualized
especially
i'm gonna just i'm gonna i think i've
already talked for a while and i
want to ask you more things but this is
i think this is
this is really important also to just be
an evolutionary experience for me and
hopefully other men that watch
this because
it's really sexy when women unleash
themselves fully
into the world i'm sorry could you say
that again just so that
everyone in the rafters can hear it's
really sexy
when women unleash themselves fully into
the world
and that's the new evolution of
consciousness
that's just what it is and the more that
we don't fight that and the more that we
ride that wave the more that we'll feel
in harmony and co-creation with
with exactly what needs to be uh
i don't i don't know about you guys but
as you know on the program
we talk a lot about things like the
sustainable development goals and we
talk a lot about things like maximizing
human potential
and enabling the gifts of everyone to
flourish and so
as you know women have a very very
biological capacity to nurture and
there's at time there's you know there's
really
the more you think about it that
oxytocin that comes from when you're
first with your mother
i mean there is really there's nothing
quite like there's
you know there's nothing quite like the
womb there's nothing quite like that
first oxytocin from a mother that just
adores you and takes care of you and
loves you and so
there are some important traits that
we could use that that love
for the planet we could use that love
for
each other there are
i'll end there for now all in there for
now because that's already a lot but
it's the first sort of things that come
to mind
as as the transitions
so there's some counterpoints to that um
and
one is society originally the men served
the women there was matriarchal
societies
and is this can you give us the examples
these are important
because we like to kind of like dig into
the
ancient civilizations where this this
occurred where were the matriarchal
societies
yeah how did those work yeah yeah those
were thousands of
thousands of years ago and i can't off
the top of my head think of a specific
civilization i am
100 sure that there's one of the
beauties from the posse
so there's there's beauties in the posse
right now the power priestess posse that
i created and they're they're watching
the live and so i'm just like
so excited like so happy um
but you know today
in this day and age there's this sense
of it's called the queen-led
relationship
the woman the female-led relationship
where the
the woman is the one that it has holds
dominion
not again in power over somebody but
like in understanding that
and i've seen multiple times now where
there's women that have been
in a relationship with a man very
masculine
not emasculated quite masculine
and they understand that their their
soul
joy is by fulfilling
whatever they can for their partner yeah
and what has
happened in their lives by doing that
like these women have become
like have shot out into the stratosphere
of like
you know in their business and their
success and their
life and their sex life and their
vibrance and their radiance
because instead of them having to take
care of all the things
they have partners who are like what is
it that is not in your genius and your
joy
what can i take and handle for you so
you can just solely be
in your magic solely be in your joy and
i've seen
multiple women i personally know they've
had that kind of
that that foundational support where
it's like i don't want to cook or i
don't want to do the dishes or i don't
want to do the bills or i don't want to
think
like these are things that pull me out
of my genius
and here's a man who like who loves me
who sees my vision who knows why i'm
here to
me meaning that woman but like you know
he sees
her he sees her vision her potential he
knows that by
by nurturing that plant by nurturing her
rather than a company or serving the man
that he's serving her from a devotional
like an
honoring from that nightly ness
that she just blasts off and they go
together you know so i i know
personally three women who've had that
become multi-millionaires over
a year or two because they've had that
kind of support
and it's like oh i'm and no dream is too
big
you know there's no shutting them down
so i had a really beautiful podcast
about that with um
with a man that's in a female-led
relationship and it's so powerful so
that's the potential of what is here
there's so many women who have so much
treasure in them so much and they're
tapped in and tuned in and they're
channeled like
the women were the original shaman the
neanderthals going back to the
neanderthals it was the women who were
the shaman
it was the women that had their wounds
were connected to the cosmic womb and
the mother womb
they were the ones that were in the
communications and the healers and
the wise women and like you know the all
of that was it was the women of the
society and they understood that
there's a channel that i did about the
reptilians and
how um and how the reptilians
you know like the the women had the
magic
and the men knew that and they wanted to
have a piece of that they wanted to
understand that they wanted to know what
it was like
to have that because the women held the
magic and the power and they understood
the nature they understood the harm
harmonics of everything of the cycles of
the moon of their cycles
of everything and so that's how the
society ran
was by following the moons it was by
being in tune with our body rhythm the
earth's rhythm
and each one of us had magic so if one
of my sisters had a magic for a certain
thing or she had a healing gift about
this thing or i had this
you know we would go to each other for
that rather than like oh she has that i
want that
it's like no i have this she is that and
those who need me will come for that
does that make sense so there's like
this yeah
sharing in this connection
and then there was and for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years men
knew
to serve the women they knew how to keep
everything in harmonic
they understood that that rhythm and
then there were
i mean there's a lot of hypotheses of
what happened but
this is that's the thing that is
probably most uh
difficult to archaeologically dig up and
figure out exactly
very difficult to figure out the exact
uh
relationship dynamics between men and
women over the last hundred thousand
years really hard to figure that out and
dig it up
so i will say that yeah so there's a
book called
the sacred prostitute and it was written
by a woman who studied psychology and
young
psychology and she was um she
received this this download to go study
the goddess archetype and the
the prostitute archetype the temple
priestess archetypes and we've been so
fractured away from the goddess in our
society
and for the the priestesses and what
that's the true story
that they held in the society when men
were coming back from war
they would come to the temples and it
was the priestesses
that would heal them and restore them
they would pull their trauma out of
their bodies they would channel the
divine feminine in
to restore them back into wholeness of
who they were before they returned home
to their families and their children
you know there was the temple was where
people came for that healing in that
connection and so
today we have this massive mother wound
massive mother wound yeah i've felt it
like there's nothing to fill that void
and that's because the goddess has been
just fractured and severed from us in
our society
and so the book talks about that and
there's pieces
of like the dominatrix started in temple
8 000 years ago in sumeria
with inanna the goddess inanna okay so
so here we go so sumerian yeah um
archaeology 8 000 years ago goddess
named inanna inanna yeah she was the
first recorded goddess in human history
and her high priestess and haduana
was the first writer in history a woman
okay and she wrote there's tablets of
her love poetry
to goddess inanna first recorded right
in history
was by a woman a priestess a high
priestess
inanna the goddess you know yeah the
goddess in honor and then she had a
writer
that's her high priest high priestess
yeah yeah and and hedawana
yeah okay
so it's really important i mean the
clarity here is really important
because any archaeological evidence that
shows
this style of of relationship the
the the unleashing of the full goddess
the
the relationship of the warriors that
are coming back and that have go through
a miraculous healing process with the
divine feminine
you know these these sorts of examples
are
really important and i mean the
for me the the sort of easiest
way to see it
right now is in just the social fabric
itself
in modernity because it's in a sense
it's where
i live now and it's in a sense it's most
easiest for me to
analyze and validate empirically through
my own data
of today rather than you know looking at
this the slightly more archaeological
and more difficult to identify
data from the past but
although there are all of these very
crucial stories and points
in the trajectory of the relationship
between the man and the woman until
until today yeah it's it's very much
so as you said
there's a
there's a profound amount of
talent and gifts that can be unleashed
more beautifully fruitfully and
it's important to catalyze that and you
know
it's funny because when you take a look
at what happens to
to women in the world in the developing
world in modernity
when there is a greater amount of of
education
and when there's a greater amount of
sovereignty
which is really the word is the supreme
having supreme authority
over oneself that's really that i guess
the whole show probably boils down to
that
honestly yeah it probably does and i and
i'd like to try and
distill things as much as possible on
the program so
i guess we spent some time in
archaeology land which was great
uh and now we're in modernity land and
there's there's lots of other things
we'll be talking about including you
brought up
the power priestess posse group
which has incredible 1600 incredible
women in it
right now that have different gifts that
are going through the different
processes
that we'll we'll be unpacking and
there's
approaching 70 000 followers on tick
tock those links are in the bio below if
you guys want to
go check out the content that is being
disseminated there
and so the reason why
it's important to bring up modernity for
me
is because there's inevitably
it's heading towards more and more
sovereignty more and more for women
especially and it's very quickly
showing that there are
radically important contributions that
they're providing
our world by becoming sovereign and
that's that's really the essence of when
you do get the
you know we talk about this a lot in
high level perception that first
analogy of the seed of the tree
and the seed of the human the roots need
the nourishment
of the tree in order for it to blossom
and have fruits the same thing is true
with the human and so
when you have just under a billion
people on the planet that don't have
access to clean water
that you're going to run into the
problem where people are
more primal where people are not able to
manifest fruits and gifts and creative
north star journeys and things like this
so i'm most excited
probably for all of the potential being
unleashed including the feminine
potential that
is that has its own unique flavor it has
it has its own unique angle
and it's
like i kind of you know i really enjoyed
it seeing it a lot in
in my mother growing up is i got to see
her step into her
flame and her energy raising me by
herself without my father and so
that was very important for me and i
think it definitely
enables me today to be able to better
see more clearly how important it is for
women to have that
sovereignty and that power and to step
into entrepreneurship to step into
creativity
and just and to just
and see here's one another thought just
for like the dynamic right if we're
going to talk about the modern dynamic
right we're talking
we talked about the the basic needs
being met that then makes
people around the planet less primal
especially women to
they'll be more educated less inclined
to
uh have uh
as we've seen the fertility rate in
itself is
uh significantly dropped to the
replacement fertility rates about
two less than two in the developing
world so every
every two people are replete are being
replaced by less than two children
you know every couple's being replaced
by less than two children in the
developed world
but the the spot where that's still
the k not the case is the development of
the
continent of africa and other places
worldwide
but the sort of the the second thing
is besides that basic needs example and
the creative flourishing there in the
modern developed world example
what we see is we see
and i loved all the past examples those
those are really really important
in sort of the the struggle sometimes
that that's visible
today is that there is a
there's some sort of a
it's like the old lions they don't want
to
let the new lions play
it's kind of the archetype in a sense
it's kind of like the old money
doesn't want the new uh the new
entrepreneurs
to come in and re-architect things
towards decentralization
and towards all of the new emerging
markets and things like that and so
in a sense it kind of almost feels a
little bit like that like the whole
old school dude at the country club
that's 80 years old playing golf every
day
is dying and it's
like that that style of consciousness is
is
dying yeah like the younger 20 year old
guy
is is is growing up in a world where
the the where they
very much so see the feminine in a way
that is it's
it's more combinatorial so in in math
you could view that as
rather than being some sort of a binary
relationship where it's
like the woman that marries the man or
the man marries
they get married and then the the woman
takes the man's last name and the woman
does these house things and the
guy goes to work and that kind of a
thing
that's like very binary there's only
kind of like one funnel
that more in mod more modern times
kind of funneled into that's completely
being obliterated with new combinatorics
so meaning like the
there's new combinations of the male
female dynamic
that are going to express completely
unique fruits
where like you said there are three
women in the
group that have experienced a different
style of relationship dynamic and
modernity with their male partner
that they've made multi-million dollar
businesses
so this is what's unique you know this
is what's
beautiful it's what's it's new
and this is the kind of stuff that
younger people are more excited about is
seeing what can
come from the north stars and
and also what especially at the time
when it's so needed
regarding the the health the mental
health
the planetary health
so you you might you might wonder if
there was
if you could visualize the data of
the
the psychometrics and the cognitive
schemas
of the
people in positions of power whether it
be the 2200 billionaires that exist or
the
fortune 500 ceos or the 225 000 ultra
high net worth or the
u.n general assembly or etc
you would wonder how much of
their psychometrics and cognitive
schemas are aware of
things like the divine feminine or are
aware of things like the seventh
generation principle of the indigenous
how many of them are aware of what
non-duality is unity consciousness is
how many of them
are aware of individuation and gifts and
maximizing the
the prosperity of the social fabric all
these types of things and so
to me this is one of the crucial pillars
along along the journey is the divine
feminine and unleashing that
fully into the world and seeing those
gifts flower and it feels like there
will be a lot more healing there will be
a lot more
love there will be a lot more holism
holism is a really good word for it it's
a really good word for it i think that's
probably
that's probably my second good word so
far i'll give myself yes
i think i think i think we did a good
job with sovereignty and holism
that those are probably two good ones uh
yeah there is a return of the divine
feminine and she so much wants to be
here on this earth and she needs
her lighthouses she needs the the men
and women but especially the women that
can hold
that frequency because it's so
desperately needed mother earth is
crying
for it the whole world is crying for it
and there's a piece of us
where is so easy to blame patriarchy
is so easy to do it i know it because
i've done it
it's so easy to like say well they're
wrong and you know
again because i've done all the things
and
that's not going to get us ahead so what
is going to help shift things and how do
we do it quickly we're no longer we are
in
an acceleration point unlike anything i
have seen and thank you
kovitz so much because it's amazing that
no matter what the ruse is or whatever
the agenda is
well you know what the divine is going
to find a way and the goddess sure
as [ __ ] found a way in to get a lot of
people turned on
and i'm talking about people are getting
activated and i've said i'm like we're
not in a time now where you're going to
be in a mystery school for 12 years to
become some kind of level of da da da
like you've got codes in you
that you came onto this earth with with
your soul and we're going to get them
switched on and turned on so you get out
into the world and do what you came here
to do
this is the time we chose this time
we chose this time the
most significant the most challenging
the most
glorious is most the most the most like
it
is this time this is the showdown and
it's like
we got to get online yeah and you and i
have had this conversation where there's
been like this like the in between
like last year i felt so lost i went
through the dark night of the soul for
months like i thought i was going insane
nothing made sense i couldn't form a
single thought
you know like the we had the symptoms
kind of before some of the wave
and there's this mass awakening
happening and all of a sudden people are
like
whoa what like wait like and their
systems are
like flipping so again i'm like so
grateful to have created a space for
women
i feel like kind of like a lady liberty
like come on i've been called that like
the women in the group they're like
you're like our lady liberty like come
come in because during this time
you are not supposed to be alone you
cannot be alone right now
you must like join in in synergy
yeah yeah together in our sovereignty
and in our synergy
to create that kind of that's beautiful
that's another good third word
i know sovereignty synergy holism okay
yeah and like bring
bringing these especially women together
because
women are tapped in they have their
feminine psyche and their cerebellum
like
they have a different way of just
feeling and connection and
so many of them have gifts and remember
that many of us if you believe in
reincarnation
many of us have had past lives as
witches as healers as priestesses as da
da da da and we lost our lives and we
gave up and we
sat like we were you know many things
happen so we come back to this
realm where we're like is it safe to
speak my truth
is it safe is it safe for me to be seen
is it safe like what's gonna happen is
someone gonna call me out i remember
that lifetime where i got you know like
so and science also calls this a lot of
this is epigenetics
of the familial lineage and so if there
have been family members in the past
especially women
uh that have had that style of of
ancestral lineage
and traumas that uh that it will come up
that idea of can is it safe for me to
speak my truth for sure absolutely and
so that
again like this is the time and and
it's taken me a couple of years to be
able to speak so
like it finally like it i had my event
so there's like you know i love the
hero's journey it's like one of my
favorite things like you know it's like
you get the call to adventure
all of us have gotten the call to
adventure to step into our power
our destiny what our soul came here to
do not what our mind is not what society
is telling us but what our soul
was like i'm here there's this mission
that i've got and our bodies are like
[ __ ] yeah i want to do that thing and so
like our soul and our body merge
our body is our soulmate and they came
here and here we are to do this thing
but we're not feeling right it doesn't
feel good we don't understand like we're
doing this other thing we're doing all
the lists of the things that everyone
tells us we should be doing and we're
unhappy we're
like we're not fulfilled we're trying to
fill ourselves with
anything to fill that that hole in us
because we're not answering the
call that our soul came here to do which
is to wake the [ __ ] up and step into our
power of who we are like we are
masters we are the chosen ones we are
the ones
that our families prayed for they the
thousands of years
of lineage where they sacrificed so much
because they knew there was going to be
a a prodigy there was going to be a
project there was going to be a chosen
child that was going to come in and
change the game
for them the whole lineage and set us
free yeah and so that's
that's this time but like i had my i had
an event a couple months ago that like
woke me up like
really strong like i because i was so is
an analog fair to say something like
mlk for for black people in the united
states
like an analog for modernity would be
something like what you're talking about
with the power priest's posse for the
divine feminine
like this sort of massive revolutionary
divine feminine awakening planetary
unleashing the gifts that kind of a
thing
like we're talking like civil rights
level
so i like i don't want to because i
i'm not it's different energy black i
don't want energy but
it's similar analog in a sense as well
yeah in the in the sense of like being a
beacon
in the sense of like let's go let's do
this and the sense of like let's step
into our courage
yes in the sense of like we came here to
create a better world and
we have to own that we did create this
we are creators
you and i created this yeah we are
co-creators and we can choose a new
game yes and instead of feeling like
we're pawns
under someone's spell which is total
[ __ ] illusion and be like i'm going
to step into the divine game i'm going
to
own my power i'm going to step in my
courage and so in this
posse in this group that i that just
came out of
again like nowhere but it's not it's
it's that foundational step that you
were talking
but we were talking about on the way to
that ecuadorian vision that you had
like these are steps yeah and none of
them made so
and that's why like in my in my posse i
talk about how
um the the way the goddess works it's
not a linear path
you don't show up and you put in the gps
and it's gonna like oh
and you can look at the map and like oh
okay so from here to two years from now
this is how we're gonna get there
that's not how magic works that's not
how the divine feminine works
divine feminine you're like you're
leaning in you're you're feeling in
and you're being you're trusting in the
thing that is not you cannot see
and that's what i've been doing so
you've seen my iterations you've seen
the things i've done like this is
like so suddenly for this to like yeah
like that like that's the number one
thing that i've been telling you
it's like it's been talking you know
this is the thing that you've been
really uh this is that first
like really big after the big huge
synthesis
is like this is that first big
foundational stepping stone to that
ecuadorian vision and we're
we're also going to get to um the
ecuadorian vision like
one so that's is that is that the same
thing as the wonderland if you can speak
to the
there's that's the star is that we won't
we won't talk about but
is that the star it's like it's a part
of the star it's a part of it
okay cool okay so then in the power
pieces posse
is post synthesis of all the different
things that you took in
it's kind of like the first the facebook
group and the tick tock comments it's
like the first
like iteration or like the first
product i don't even know like it just
it launched and
i just i i knew that it was time to
speak my voice and
i chris i couldn't hold like we can't we
have to be in our courage
and so this facebook group that i
started
you know i just i wanted a safe space
for women to come in and step into their
power and their magic and their joy
and have courage like the currency of
this group
is courage courage to speak our truths
courage to show our
our pieces our shadows like courage to
step into that and do our shadow
work like like it's like for anyone
that's in
any kind of spirituality right now
learning be able to do their shadow work
and there's
various forms of it but it's the
probably one of the most
quint essential things because if we're
not willing to see our dark and we're
not willing to go into our shadows
we're not willing to acknowledge that
you know there's we're all the things
that we see in society is in us too
it just is and we've got to go in there
and go into those pieces and heal them
in ourselves and find our treasures that
are in there
so i've created a very very safe space
um and and the women have too you know
it's not just me but it's like it means
all of us it's that synergy
it is the synergy but like there's this
foundation piece of like
it's okay and i want you to be like i'm
like i'm not here to snuff you out i'm
here to build you up because
the goddesses are calling on us we they
need the lighthouses
they need the channels so i'm an oracle
so the difference between a channel and
an oracle is a channel someone like you
like you almost you type you hit a radio
button and there's
uh you know music or sound or whatever
that comes out and oracle some
is someone who like shares space
like steps in and it's like the divine
or whoever you call and descends and
like puts you on like a suit
and like starts being embodied
so when you see women who are channeling
the divine feminine through dance and
through movement their
their oracles their their channeling
they're bringing it in
you know it's this this movement piece
so the the priestesses that are doing
all of that
so so the channel and oracle have a lot
of in overlap
yeah there's tons of overlap yeah it's
just the the channel is kind of more
static and the oracle is
more embodied and um and so
yeah it's just an embodiment so this is
what the divine this is what the goddess
wants she wants the embodiedness yeah
yeah
of of her and and that's in the artist
that's in the healers that's in the
empire
it's in all those those pieces those
nurturers and all that the
the divine feminine there's so many
aspects of her and i so i
i strive to bring all of those aspects
in
and then call the beauties forth
and up and share and let's go
so um yes it's so what's happened
in this group is now there's over 1600
women that are
in their mystics they're witches they're
healers or
priests or oracles or shamans that you
know and there's such a magical group of
incredible incredible women
and a few sacred men very careful who i
led into the posse
and um and it's gorgeous and so so now
i'm seeing i'm like this is the vision
that's coming to life
and there's a lot of the women that come
in with abuse
and traumas that haven't been resolved
and there's
there's a bit of a stuckness like you
can't really step into your power
if you're not able to heal go down into
those pieces
first and be willing to see that and and
slay and cut off the
like the not themselves but the things
that don't belong to them
from the predators and the perpetrators
and the abusers and how to like
face that i mean like no more like
you're no longer being a part of my life
and so it's just it's it's such a rich
amazing group i'm so proud of the women
and how they've shown up for
for me and each other and and the world
and how they're stepping into their
communities and like
starting things and this is just after
two months this is two months
two months and like these women are
having tremendous breakthroughs
and it's such an honor and a privilege
to like hold that space and then
like okay what's the and how do we set
more fires
how do we light more torches how do we
get this going
yeah yeah because if we all come
together as that like that like we set
the sky on fire
so um you know but it's being willing to
go to our shadows and when
we as we've been taught it's not okay to
go into our darkness it's not okay to be
angry
like be nice it swallow we've silenced
so much of ourselves
our nose or our yes we've swallowed our
desires we've designed we've swallowed
so much of of
our truths of who we are what we don't
want what we do want so
so really empowering them
and embodying that and being in a state
of vulnerability i go live
nearly every single day in that group
and i'm sharing
everything and then they're seeing my
emotion they're seeing my life they're
seeing
what's going on for me they're seeing me
process my shadows right there with them
like
so they're getting that yes that
permission
to be all of who they are and that it's
safe to do it and it's
celebrated it's gorgeous it's amazing
there's nothing
i i promise you i have never seen
anything like it and for so many of the
women to say i feel like i'm home
that is everything
yeah yeah
yeah i love i feel like i'm home that's
that's huge yeah to have that feeling
sink into the heart
and to have that synergy of other women
stepping into their courage as their
currency that's that's it yeah that's
so i want to
explore with you the
whatever you feel comfortable sharing
about
the examples
because you you we're we're very
we're we're giving kind of the high high
level macro
level of going into the shadow
integrating achieving gifts that being
the courage
let's get an example
or two in about
that process that has unfolded in
however
w in whatever way you want to describe
to you know keep
the you know data
how you know disclosed in whatever way
you want so do you mean like for
individuals yeah probably in probably
some of like if you can give us just
like the
most give us some of the like
the stuff that was really hard to get to
get through and to unlock and to
i would like to i'd like to hear that um
um so there's one of the beauties in the
posse
who um went through a lot she
lost her mother to cancer at 14 and
because of uh
yeah and she was her best friend and
everything and
because of the the depression she went
through afterwards her father wanted to
put her into a teen
rehab center or you know teen
yeah rehab center kind of place and uh
institution and it
it's those are actual centers of severe
abuse that are happening
here in the united states and she was
transported
and shuttled through the night in the
middle of the night away
to these different places where they
were having
children teenagers hiking for multiple
hours a day or
or another facility where you couldn't
have your feet dangling off the bed you
had to sit cross-legged for hours
on your bed like you couldn't leave it
and there was one facility that she was
at
and each one was more severe she has
in the six months she was there she has
a binder this thick of the
number of times they restrained her for
no reason
and of all the the drugs that they put
her
on and into there were above and beyond
what are normal
acceptable standards and they kept her
there because she was a private patient
so for a year and a half there was
and they were keeping her mail from her
father
like they were monitoring everything so
she couldn't share with him what was
going on
geez and so she in those times she knew
that no one was gonna come and save her
and she was gonna have to do whatever it
took
to get out you know so and she's a
she has such a huge heart so she you
know she got out
and um you know she's been on a healing
journey meant through
just a lot of things and i have so much
um admiration for her because she has
this
she's um
like there's she's unbelievable like
there is there's
for her she has such love she wants to
take care of help so many
and help animals and people and so she
came into the posse
like she she found she found me on tik
tok which is how i've
organically grown my group has only
like 99 percent of it has been through
tick tock
and she came on and i started doing my
lives and
um you know she's in her late 20s now
and it was the one week from when i
started the posse and she was like i
love
you know this group has been everything
to me um she showed up at a couple of my
ceremonies and things
events i was doing and she wrote um
i stopped taking my antidepressants two
days ago
yeah and i just started like bawling
like on on the live you know
to read something like that and i didn't
know her story i didn't even know any of
that
i didn't know any of her backstory all i
knew was that
first comment that was her first comment
was that she was
off of her antidepressants and i just
started bawling because i'm like
she's like i finally feel good yes yes i
finally feel like i'm
home i finally feel good i finally feel
safe i finally feel like people like
see me i finally you know and and she's
so
brave she's a woman of courage
like truly for me and then we find out
her backstory and then it's like
holy [ __ ] like she went through all of
these things and she still has such a
a huge heart and desire to help others
and to find forgiveness and like
what a gift what a gift to have her in
the group and what a gift to be able to
provide this space for her
to really help her her blossom and step
into her leadership and
step into her beacon and like she's a
very powerful powerful
woman and um and and help and
and she's getting acceleration so her
gifts like her psychic gifts and her
abilities
are accelerated and they're like just
completely
exploding how did she heal
how did she what was her healing process
that's that's a lot of
yeah yeah dying and then jumping for all
those facilities
and yeah how did she heal to become the
person that wants to heal the
humans and animals and yeah um she
definitely did a lot of therapy
and i think she'd be a wonderful person
for you to interview excellent yeah and
go
deeper into but that's like an exit like
the power priestess posse knows now
because i sent a video i know i know
let me know when you're coming through
los angeles yeah
always let me know yeah so there's
so much space here to be held for you to
share your journey and your gifts
and you love to do that so yeah and
there's a there's
it's also cool that that she came
through from tiktok and that actually
like that's a really important point is
that to create those creative
videos that enable people to see
you stepping into the power priestess
mode
that then get makes them go i want to be
a part of that group
yeah that's really cool that's huge and
you said 99
yeah from there oh yeah like i like it's
organically so
maybe at this point it's in 96 maybe
because there's other
beauties who are inviting friends in you
know but i've
i've only personally invited in a
handful of my friends because i wanted
to see
i wanted i wanted to create something
from who i am at this moment
you know like i wanted people to meet me
at in this moment
and like bring me you know not have the
the past stories and
oh you know
it's like they mean me here at this
moment and they're like
oh dang yeah like i like what she's
about like great because this is
who i am and what i'm about so like come
like let's go
and you know so it's a it's a again it's
an opportunity and so then and then
there's like select
you know like you like you know people
that i've known that like i've i've
selectedly
yes um brought in but there's another um
another question briefly prior to that
will you also
explain what the questions
are for that are required to be answered
by the
the the people that want to enter the
group so what are your
entry questions that they have to answer
like
how do you feel how do you parse
a vet yeah so it's been a while since
i've added so i closed the doors three
weeks ago
um to the temple because
for for a variety of reasons because i
understood that if we grow too fast
that it's hard to keep the the synergy
and the the vibe you know if we like you
know there was one when we went from 500
members to a thousand in a day oh you
went in a day
in a day like one day yes how did that
happen you had to accept manually 500
people
yes oh and we just like took this way
is that when your million hit video hit
was that
some yeah something around that time
like there was just this huge spike one
day and like i woke up and i was like oh
my god there was like
hundreds of people and so i was like
yeah listen you know so we
we started out with like oh this is good
this is cozy we're at like 100 we're at
200 we're at 500 and then the next day
we're a thousand
and it's like you know and so that
kind of threw everyone's head because a
lot of them were like commenting on
everyone's
posts and you know there's a lot of
interaction and stuff and now
sudden like we doubled numbers and so
the beauties who felt like they wanted
to help
you know again like building the fire
because it's not me it's not
just me like it's all of us you know
so then we but we were growing again and
again we got to 1600
and you know then there was just just a
few
kind of i wanted to really again like
cultivate
cultivate what we've got cultivate that
fire rather than like
keep throwing more wood on but if the
fire's not strong enough right and so
yeah so i haven't looked at the
questions in a while but there's
really good analogy yeah yeah the fire
the synergistic fire
has got to be strong between basically
it's like 500 or a thousand nodes that
are all
harmonizing and interconnecting but then
if you dump like a thousand more nodes
on
then it if the flame's not bright enough
as those
logs come on that's a really good
analogy thank you
yeah thank you that's a good one thank
you
i mean it's right here it kind of just
laid itself out for me um
yeah so right now we have over 600
people who want to get in
geez over 600 and um so among the
questions
are like how did you find us and most
people will say like through tick tock
and i'll say and are you courageous
courageous and committed
to your path are you courageous and
committed
to your path yeah that's a great
question and um and i
and i put in parentheses and you can't
put down just
yes like or something like that and then
um why do you wish to enter
the posse and you can't just say
you know because i'm curious you can't
just say that you're curious
oh yeah
yeah i'm just curious i'm like no i
don't want you like i want the
courageous and committed i don't want
the curious
i want the courageous and committed into
this group because this is a
this is a high voltage acceleration
velocity
group like there is massive
transformation that's happening
very fast very quickly for a lot of the
women so
um you know there's there's one of my
one of the beauties and the posse she
was like also one of the very first to
see me and she wrote and i still have
the text on the video
that's been seen a million times over a
million almost one and a half million
times
her comment still comes up at the top
which is like i feel like i've known you
you are a teacher of mine in a past life
yeah
and so she's in the group and i've
helped her
you know cultivate her channeling
abilities and what she's done she's
stepping in as
as an oracle for goddess kali and like
you know pulling that in and she wrote
me a message
that i have that she sent me the other
day and she said you are the best
teacher i've ever had
and you know i i've been able to step
into my channeling and i'm
i'm preparing myself to be a lighthouse
and i'm serving my community
and you know things like that and like
that i mean
what could be better than that right
than like these these women who are
coming in
and there's women who are like who are
stepping up to their abusive partners
and they're like
no more i'm done you're going to treat
me like that again this is over
you know there's women that are doing
that there's a lot of women like that
there's a
woman that's great that's excellent yeah
where my ego oh
i guess my tea is gone um
so look it's coming back oh the t is
magically appearing
potentially
no that was good but i just like the mug
thank you so much
we have thank you very much
okay oh exciting um
oh i love you jessica you are beyond
strong courageous amazing and a true
queen god i honor you do you want to
read it yeah
if you want to read it that's that'd be
great that's a good idea
okay oh
thank you
um they were layla uh so one of my
i adore this she is the sweetest
sweetest thing
um she wrote i love you jessica you are
beyond strong
courageous amazing and a true queen
goddess i honor you
um she is like she's a powerhouse
there's so many powerful powerful women
and they get to show up in their and
their gifts and their abilities
and their healing like capabilities and
it's um truly like fantastic
it's such an honor um but again like
they're given
are you're opening it women's rule women
rule a look at five
matriarchal societies throughout history
may we may we actually this this would
be this would be briefly
um excellent so so you could scroll and
i'll like
share so the classic example that has
been used for a while
is uh is north africa
and that's the most common example that
i've heard
um so here we have uh new nubia
kush empire in sudan we have the
trobryanders of papua new guinea we have
the palawan society of the philippines
we have the khasi society of india
and the mosul society of china
so interesting so masuo is m-o-s-u-o
mosul society in china khasi society in
india's k-h-a-s-i
society in india palawan society in
philippines p-a-l-a-w-a-n society
and the trobrianders of papua new guinea
is t-r-o-b-r-i-a-n-d-e-r-s
of papua new guinea and the nubia kush
empire of sudanese n-u-b-i-a
so that that's really good so we'll
start with those examples
um to help us archaeologically dig in
history and anthropologically and
anthropologically anthropologically
archaeologically
super important yeah yeah okay so we so
that was that the second
person that you want to share or who's
okay no just
you know i'm just like i'm popping up
with like that's great you know things
are coming up you know
uh women that are stepping forth and
sharing their offerings of like what
their gift is
sorry sorry i i just i need to re i need
to take a second to also just
remember that you said that
that there are women stepping into their
courage to tell
their abusive partners that this is the
last time yeah that's it
yeah because that that one that one's a
little bit um
that one kind of hits me a little harder
yeah so let's let's pause with that yeah
and just like be with that that one hits
me harder for sure
um yeah
there's a lot of that one's bad there's
there's a lot of
women who you know
again we sacrifice we give up
our body our safety or we give up our
body and our love
or for love you know we give ourselves
up to
to our abusers i was in an abusive
relationship
before i met you like you know two years
ago i was
it was with him and he was verbally
abusive
mentally psychologically emotionally
but he didn't hit me yeah so
you know but he was absolutely like
it came down to a moment there was there
was one night he like threatened my life
after watching a show and was like if
you ever did something like that to me i
would kill you
and i'm like on what
planet would this scenario ever ever
happen and he's like if you ever did
something like that would kill you and
i'm like how did i get here
like we have those moments like how did
i get here
and we had and then it's
like you know you can have all the
people in the world telling you
this is not a good guy you need to get
out of this relationship
but there comes a moment
there comes a moment where you're like
i'm [ __ ] done
i am not doing this another day and i
had that day
that happened and i made sure like he
was off to work he was super happy and
then i packed all my stuff
left a note drove to my best friend's
house gave her my phone
so that i couldn't even answer his calls
for two days
and i tapped out and when i
chose my life over a relationship my
whole it was like
knocking the first domino over of my
life and everything changed
but the amount of courage and it
couldn't be anyone talking me into it i
had to like feel
it inside where i'm like no more i'm
done and that spark that
fire that heat that's the dom that is
our dominatrix that is the woman and
we've
kept her i have kept her in the back
seat do clean up crew when [ __ ] hits the
fan
our dominatrix steps in is like alright
this is done game over let's go
she's in there she's in here that that
moment when women are like i'm done i am
out it is
over that's that's our dom that's our
inner dominatrix
i want her to be the bodyguard yeah i
want her to be at the front
not doing cleanup crew when they're like
all right let's see how oh oh she's
going to do that okay
all right well wait oh oh no not enough
okay
all right how long when are you gonna
when are you gonna when are you gonna
tap out
but there's that moment and so that's
the other thing too is for these women
to understand how powerful it is
they can actually step in and claim who
they are
and then take that take that action
yeah because nothing and no one has
power over them
and do i fall sure
you know but we're going to do this
together and
for a lot of them to know that they're
not alone
they've got a huge support network now
yeah of emotional
like love and caring
and i actually that you would be a
good person to go have
had the power priestess posse to go into
when you made the oh my god so then
that's like a really good example of
sort of
uh a place to be able to like i had
enough of that
that was that was the last straw i have
i've packed up i've left and now
my phone's with my best friend and i
like
maybe i log in and i check in on that
power presses policy group and i
make a you know a video and i maybe have
a
call with some of the other members that
can
relate you know that relationship of
that that that they're able to sort of
as having went through similar things
that's a really important thing when
someone when you can relate with someone
else on a level of wisdom that they've
been through and experienced like that
because that's yeah that one really that
one really hit
that that's and thanks for sharing your
example yeah
i mean that was two years ago and i and
i'm i was a strong woman
you wouldn't be here yeah i was i was
still like
strong i was still confident i was so
great at my job i was all of those
things your sovereignty was second
oh my god and i was staying in a
relationship because
because he saw that i was the one but i
was like
really like you're not who i had in mind
as that
as that guy so i wasn't trusting myself
when i actually spoke my truth
three months into the relationship that
should have cut it but it didn't we kept
going it was a disaster but it was
and it was important and we both went on
our journeys and you know it's
it's good now but it took a lot oh man
oh so you know
but in this posse it's you know it's for
all of the women you know if they're
baby witches and they've never you know
or they're just starting to open up to
their gifts or they're getting curious
or they're going into their dark knight
of the soul or
they're in it or they're emerging or
they're stepping in or they're the
the high priestess and the elders and
the shamans you know like all of the you
know and
but and there just happens to be within
that group a lot of women who've been
through
sexual abuse sexual trauma like
different kinds of or
other kinds of abuse and so and then
that's when i'm like
oh i have a lot of responsibility yeah
and i like it calls me to be
how i show up as straight and clear
as i possibly can because i have this
the
integrity value that i have is very very
high
of like how i show up and how i speak in
who i be
and there's also incredible like you
know
potters and lawyers and business women
and art again like all the all the it's
just this really gorgeous gorgeous
gorgeous mix so um but
again it's like helping them to step
into their magic and into their power
and and trust that magic is real
like that there's we call it the holy
[ __ ] magic like it is
real when we line up when we commit when
we
get the intuition and we answer the call
i say that all the time
answer the call yeah exactly and that's
what they're there for
and we're all in it together so so those
are the questions those are the
questions
like you know yeah goddess is knocking
are you gonna answer and are you gonna
do whatever it takes did i know a year
ago when i was being
like hey jess you know what i know this
dominatrix thing is
kind of scary and completely outside of
your comfort zone even though it felt
kind of natural
but you know just wait because in a year
and a half you're going to start this
thing
and it's going to be [ __ ] awesome
there's going to be amazing women in it
and you're going to be able to teach
them
what you learned but in a way to embody
it you know it's going to be really
[ __ ] incredible and it's going to be
worth it i had no guarantee of that
yeah that was not a promise yeah yep
and that's like the thing and like same
thing for you like you know we just
entered ourselves
like you you step in into the thing so
like i like i say that to the women
because i and and anybody because i want
them to
know that that is it's harder to step
into that courage when
the amount of the trauma in the roots of
that human seed
has not been properly integrated and
addressed and
that type of thing because you know if
you don't have a group like
the power process policy to to go into
and then
furthermore if you don't have friends
that can relate or
that you can share with and that you can
you know that's why you said that you
can't
be alone anymore that you have to come
in
to this fire synergy to really be able
to rock it
rock it up like that this awakening
journey is very challenging to do on
your own
and that's something where i wanted to
be that person that i didn't have
amen yeah i wanted to be the person i
didn't i had no
guide i had no guide i went
i mean goddess isis i surrendered to her
i trusted
i walked in faith and a lot of doubt but
i
in fear but i still i still did it i
didn't have someone like me and
[ __ ] if i did yeah wow and so to be
in this spot in this time right now
where there's the a massive awakening
happening and a massive activation
happening
that we're not spiritually bypassing
that is not an
option you know we're not like again
we're going into our shadows we are
going to do
that that sense of like facing our our
triggers when we get triggered that's
our gateway that's our gateway down into
our our shadows and accessing them and
finding the truth in there and feeling
the feelings and letting the emotions
run
and like finding our treasures
underneath that and our power and all of
that stuff so
you know these are these are the tools
that we
you know that we cultivate and we bring
in together and there's
hundreds of women that are just so
freaking supportive of each other
and it's um it's miraculous it's a
vision that
um i i had and i've held with
two other incredibly important women in
my life misty and marie
and i could not sh we would not be here
in this moment
without them yeah misty and marie
and jen and lisa especially misty and
marie because they showed up
every time every time and
what we built we started something on
lionsgate where we wanted to create
a safe haven a rejuvenation haven for
child trafficking kids kids that have
been trafficked you know we want to
create a safe haven where they could
return to their innocence and
enjoy and be in that again and then like
um
here we are like two three months later
and there's a bunch of women who are
in our space that are returning into
their magic and their joy and their
innocence
and it's like you know we've we held
that
that vision and that dream and they came
like you know and there's more to come
um so it's and and part of that
responsibility of
understanding the traumas that are
coming in and and the women
and me also recognizing that i'm not
fully
adapt adept at them like i want to bring
in
more um true guides like more
people that that that is their passion
and their genius is to supporting the
women
through healing modalities or
non-traditional
to support them through their sexual
traumas and
through whatever the abu whatever it is
that's been holding them down
and supporting them um because they're
such brilliant
amazing amazing teachers and guides out
there
and and they're here and i want i want
them to be able to help the the posse
but also make sure that they're taken
care of too so
i'm partnering with a non-profit called
i thrive inc
and it's all about raising funds
to help support that to bring
in non-traditional healing therapies for
those who've been through
abuse and traumas and also supporting
them in entrepreneurship
in helping them business development and
being able to step up and take those
gifts and those offerings that are in
their hearts and in their souls and in
their callings to be and do and then
creating a system
where they're able to be held in that
and within that framework
is the is the wonderland is the vision
that i saw in ecuador two years ago of a
marketplace
where the artists are the artisans are
um and the healers and there's like
offerings there and there's
coaches and there's ceremonies and
there's events and then there's a
community component and
you know there's elixirs and like you
know it is literally a divine feminine
city
that would be built online and that that
is the vision
until it can be manifested onto the 3d
earth terra firma but we can do it
online and
welcome in people into this magic city
of wonderland where the women these
beauties of the posse they want to be
citizens of wonderland and so coming
into this space
where an everyday person or a curious
person could come in
and explore and then get to experience
the magic and the potency
and the love that these beauties have
been cultivating and building
with their offerings and everything so
that's the big
i love the north star and i'm glad that
we unpacked that massive vision
it's you as you were talking about it i
was
getting excited because you're you're
you're selling it really well
i was getting excited that's probably
why you have the
followership on tick tock and the growth
of the facebook group at where it's at
because
that's that's quite the pitch for the
north star vision that's
that's good it is possible and we need
it and so to your point
about sovereignty women need to be able
to unders
i do for sure is like how do we create a
sustainability for ourselves when so
much we've been taught just give our
gifts away
so how can we create a sustainable peace
how can we
learn some business acumen in a way that
is in the
divine feminine way of doing business
and the divine feminine way of doing
business is where
everybody wins there is a win-win-win
across the board yeah there is not like
the
you know you lose yeah so even in like
it was for everybody
yeah yeah so like in economics we call
these decisions the nash equilibrium the
individual can make a decision that
benefits them
and the collective these styles of
omni-win most of it is kind of like
civilization design protocols and
architectures that prioritize that
omni-win
strategy rather than the win-lose
strategy and it's really
it's it's a lot of it's game b a lot of
it is
sort of this emerging group and field
called game b
and it's a it's a very beautiful and
important group because it's basically a
lot of people that are
understanding that game a is not
sustainable so there's actually an
interesting synergy between
game b and the divine feminine here that
i previously did not tie together but
those are those are very intertwined
because that is the omni win and
masculine that sees it that way is going
to be a really strong co-creator for
that
future you know i want that so much and
i know that there's
i know that there's people out there
that have funds and resources and
they're like where can we put something
that
is actually going to grow something
things will actually bloom from
my contribution you know and there are
these these women that are
super hungry you know they're super
hungry and they're
they will pull in and learn and
integrate and they're here to do the
work
like they're not shying away they're not
looking for someone to rescue them
that's been one of my tenants is like
we're going in and we're we're doing
this because
how how pro so when you
i had this moment in i was at a
retreat and i was unleashing i was in
the center of the circle
and i knew that it was huge huge energy
that i was letting
go of and i fully expected i had
actually pre
predestined that there was going to be
one of the facilitators a man that i
felt strong enough to hold that
like okay here's a man strong enough to
hold that and like he can handle it
and like so i'm like roaring i'm
throwing my clothes off i'm having like
i am
exploding like just letting out this
pent-up stuff
and i open my eyes expecting him to come
in
and instead it is the female facilitator
who is this five foot one colombian
shaman woman and she comes in she's like
okay
okay here we go we're gonna go down
we're gonna go
down there let's go like what do you
want to do and she like we were like
and she [ __ ] threw it down damn that
energy sounds awesome
she is amazing she's literally she
she taught me more about being a shaman
than anybody i don't think i've ever
heard of a
feminine presence like that that's
that's a kind that that'd be a great
guest on the program
oh my god she's awesome holy cow yeah
yeah she and she's like one minute she
can be laughing next moment crying the
next moment yelling the neck but she's
so
in her truth in every moment and showing
up and like and showing up like that and
so she taught that to me and i was like
every [ __ ] time every time i think
that man's gonna come and rescue me do
you know what it's a woman who shows up
and she's like
hey i got you we're going down yeah
we're not
we're not scooping we're we're going
down we're going to go down to the root
of this
yeah and and that i have such massive
respect for it and so that's how i
try to get trained that's how i was
trained and like that's
how i want these women because again
like we're building lighthouses we're
building beacons
and i'm like i'm and i'm telling them
like blinders up like focus on your work
right now take out the distractions like
all the
disruption and distraction that's
happening they're trying to keep you out
of your center
focus like get into your power like
let's do the work
because it's going to become very very
important what we do and how we show up
in this world
and i want them to be trained as
warriors because this is a spiritual war
that we're in
and like king solomon trained his
healers to be warriors and his warriors
to be healers and he brought in the best
of the land to help train his people and
i feel that way too
in this temple in this city that we have
in warcraft 2 the paladins that were the
really good fighting units
were also the ones that you could
upgrade to become healers
and they would heal the hp of the other
characters in the game there are very
interesting
ways of game design that are related
deeply to
the historical lineage so it's king
solomon
king solomon and it was king solomon's
warriors that were healers and healers
that were warriors yeah and he he
scoured
he scoured the world and he he like sent
his people out and
like i want the best i want the the best
and that's what he did
and there's just there's this essence in
that that like
you know for anyone who wants to say
like evil doesn't exist
or there's a lot of light workers are
like i don't i don't i don't acknowledge
that there's evil
i'm only going to focus on this and
that's fine
but i also find that to be very
irresponsible and i've worked with
teachers like that
and um and and it's like if you
if you're not going to acknowledge it
it's like you're trying to face this
world with your hands behind your back
and your eyes closed
sri aurobindo and the mother mira
alfossa
who were two of probably the greatest
spiritual collaborators that have ever
existed
uh they have a a way to look at that
which is really good which is that
what transcends the
the truth of the good and evil is the
truth of the good
and that those hold simultaneously
they work simultaneity is key so in that
scenario it's that there is this yin
yang
harmonic flux that's occurring between
that dark and that light
that good and that evil but there's a
truth that contains that and that's the
truth
of what this is yeah and that that that
simultaneity is key so don't just say
does not exist
realize that they do co they coexist
harmonize but then that truth that many
people speak of that they
focus on that light is usually what
encompasses them
together and so we have to sort of see
that
visually in order for it to
to what i would say kind of more to make
it more
integrated into our our psyche
and i'll just i'll just quickly i'll
just very quickly just like
visually illustrate i have this camera
over my shoulder where i can actually
just
briefly show you what i'm talking about
it's just
it's just basically something like this
and then and this would be your your
classic
truth light
you know lie or false and then dark
and then those are in you know those are
in harmonic
ascension those are in harmonic
ascension
and then that's that lead that's in a
yeah exactly that one's that one's
ridiculously profound
god i love this one and so then that
happens in the oral both form but then
the idea is that
is that the as it as it goes in its
ascension
you know that's the idea is that the
truth encompasses
everything it encompasses all of this so
that's the one thing that usually
happens is that sometimes people will
will only
hone in on on just this kind of
metaphysical truth
and they'll say that this does not exist
and that but that's not the right way to
see it's to see it happening in the
ascension in the oroboros
but to say that everything that is
happening
is in fact true good and beautiful but
that within that true good and beautiful
exists this harmonic ascension it's just
been it's just been a crucial
sort of visual for me um and
and hopefully it's helpful for for other
people like
that also indicates like you [ __ ]
have to do your shadow work like there
is
you know that's the other thing about
that that it's trying to say you know
sri aurobindo and the mother mira
fasa said that the spiritual ascent and
descent happened simultan
simultaneously so you know that that's a
very important
phrase for for people to remember and
it's kind of funny because
that's also the um you know it's funny
because that's also newton's third law
of motion
you know for every action there's an
equal and opposite reaction
and that that's the same thing with the
spiritual ascent and i
described that in the trajectory
mechanics in chapter two and high level
perception
and so you you you really have to
remember that like that's
that is such a big key to remembering
that that
trauma in those roots triggers the
treasure of the fruits
but you have to go through that process
the spiritual ascent and descent happen
at the same time
so to sit there as the knocks keep
coming and to not answer them
you and that's why there is this need
there is this
calling for like you described like the
thing that i would have also given when
i was
19 years old moving to silicon valley
with all my
word documents full of ideas i was just
thinking oh my gosh
i'll just find that mentor and that
person that will
help me realize the foundations of
entrepreneurship and
and will rocket me off and that's what i
hope to help
people be right now for them for those
19 year olds
and that's the same thing with with you
right now with what you're doing
you want to be that foundation for what
you didn't have you know two years ago
you're you're making that foundation
right now for people that's the mother
again the mother wound the mother wound
and sister wound are
very strong and uh also a wound with men
i mean we've got like they're him
you know and and there's a very very
uh very few men who are i i know there's
many good men
and there are very few who are really
stepping up and not just stepping up but
showing up
yeah i'm really showing up and i cannot
tell you
actually how disappointed i am with a
lot of them and
i kept i'm like where are my brothers
where are my brothers
and i'm like okay guess we're not coming
all right sisters we gotta train up
and and thank you you know well it
required me
getting you know initiated i mean
really what what your process
triggered in me was the acknowledgement
of this even existing
there's so many people that are like
what is she talking divine feminine
you know and that's required although i
had been exposed to
you know the unity of existence and all
of these things through my own in
experiential practices that i had
undergone across the spiritual
traditions and anthogens and all these
other types of things even
scientifically with the universe the one
song that i had went through all of that
but i had not
went through the that that divine
feminine
initiation and like that really like i
hope this also
acts as that for for men in a way that
you know is portrayed through you know
through
you in a way that is more inclusive and
harmonic
and not in a way that is kind of
at other times can be you know thought
of as kind of like
you know like in a sense like sometimes
guys can think about like
kicking guys to the like to the side
it's not that
it's not that it's the it's the it's the
twin flame
at a more harmonic level and that's
that's all that's really that's that's
really what it is for me
it's just that it's that i like
like that yin yang that we just saw that
yin yang is that masculine and that
feminine
right and that that that relationship to
be at its absolute
peak capacity is all that we're talking
about that's
yeah yeah yeah i and i know i could do a
whole other yes
a whole other show and i would i would
love to because
i i believe that men are cut off from
the
from the hurt down from the waist down
oh sure in terms of like stepping in and
that's their dark masculine
and they've been like taught like they
look around and see what the dark
the with the wounded masculine or the
distorted dark masculine looks like
which is the violence and everything
that they see
but there's actually like a very deep
deeper power in the trueness of that
but so they're like i'm just going to
meditate i'm just going to be
really conscious i'm just going to dig
it and they're they're just they're
really focused up here
but their power is down here and that's
what we're calling forth
is like pulling that that up and so for
me like
and you can i see it in spiritual
leaders male ones
who oftentimes get taken down by their
sex shadow
oh yeah yeah that that's yeah that's
that's a very common one that's a that's
a good one
yeah and i there was a spiritual leader
that
earlier this year that had that downfall
and i reached out to him directly as
everyone is bailing on him and does not
want to be associated with him and is
pulling out
everyone's pulling away and i'm going in
and i'm like hey
let's do some work like let me like let
me help you
like i'm i'm willing to go in there
that's what i want i'd be happy to do
that
you can't do it yeah but that that's the
that sex shadow piece that
men don't look at that predator that's
in them
that they're not willing to face and
look at we it will eat them
it will eat them that's right i have to
deal with a lot of that still i'm
working on it i'm working on it myself
so that's
that's that's always there i am not
afraid to work with men in their shadow
i would be
freaking honored to do that because we
need more
good men that are in their power and not
afraid of it
and you know in and owning that and and
channeling that and doing it in a way
that's safe and and that
again that's the path purpose of a
dominatrix is she creates a safe space
for people to come in and access all
parts of themselves without judgment
i want to help you know so there's that
peace too
so anyways um you know
a priestess ultimately for me being a
priestess is someone who
i am in devotion to the goddess
and i'm in service to her and as
and being a channel for her or an oracle
for her in service
to those who she loves and that's
that's been it's been the singularly
most fulfilling
role that i've had and out of everything
that i've done
in my life to come here to this moment
and be all of those pieces together
synthesized as that priestess the
priestesses
were the wealthy women in society the
priest says were the vip of the vip
the priestess is when they walked into
the room people would
bow because they saw that she was a
living embodiment of the goddess
the mary magdalene was a priestess she
was a priestess she was not a prostitute
she was a temple
priestess she was allowed into the homes
of men
where no other woman would have access
to because she was a priestess and she
was doing ceremony when she was
cleansing
yeshua's feet with her hair that was a
priestess
ritual that she did so
that's the the call too is for us to
understand that priestesses were
wealthy they were revered they had like
beyond
privileges that the ordinary woman
didn't have because
that they were in service to the
community they were in service to
the goddess and that's something else
that i'm here to
revive and rebirth is that and we have
incredible
incredible incredible priestesses in in
the posse
such an honor such an honor
yeah stewardship yeah yeah
exactly yeah
wow so the priestess
serves the goddess she's devoted
devoted to the goddess yeah yeah i like
that yeah
so we have we have sovereignty we have
holism we have synergy
and we have serving the goddess yeah
these are great
yeah i love that serving her i do what
pleases me
what pleases me is to serve on behalf of
the goddess
yes and how i do that is
however way someone comes to me i pull
from my
many tools and my many gifts yes to show
up and serve
yeah as an embodiment of the goddess
that's right yeah interesting
the way that i the way that i do it from
the way that i am is i don't give a
i don't really like i just i just see
the soul
i see the soul in the other and that
then
i accelerate their flame with the
different tools that i have under the in
the belt so
i just see the soul and then accelerate
the flame with the tools that i have
and the wisdom that i've attained and
things like that so
to me it doesn't like for to me like the
like
it being a guy or a girl or whatever
their walk of life being
yeah like i just i just see the soul and
that
that
that kind of thing i think is really
helpful it's super important i mean of
course then
all of the other aspects to the roots of
their
of of who they are is of course
important as well but
to sort of see it at that soul level in
service of that
basically in service of their of the
north star ultimately the nature of
reality
has a very fundamental essence to it
being the north star the north star
achievement of the individual plays a
fundamental role
in the nature of reality and so you're
in service to that
i'm in service to that and i call it we
call it the star of venus
so this symbol where's the camera
yes yes yes um
this is one of the most ancient symbols
of the goddess
is the star of venus and so inanna isis
aphrodite they would consider planet
venus the star
of venus and so this particular symbol
is very very powerful and i've
resurrected it too and it's
a manifestation tool it's an amplifier
um i send these to the beauties and the
posse
and one of my friends put it up against
an
amethyst and it increased its power by
10 he could feel it
the energy of it so we're bringing her
back
you know we're bringing her back in
every way that we can through
through our dance through our our love
through our joy
and the more you can be in your joy and
get into your channel
the sooner you're able to so i guess
this is the last point that i want to
share
beautiful um and we have your power
priestess posse
logo right next to your head right now
and it has that
again it's venus the star of the the
star
venus i love that and so that's been
used very frequently to identify that
divine feminine
it used to be okay i'm bringing it bring
it i love that
we're bringing it back i love that yes
they call it the it's the um eight
pointed star is the
rosette um it's you know there's
different variations of it but
that iteration um that's what i'm
bringing back in so
um but yeah i the last part i want to
share is for anybody
especially right now if you're like what
do i do right now
um the more that you can step into your
joy
the closer you are to being connected to
your channel
and when you're connected to your
channel you're connected to your
higher self and then ultimately the
divine and as you're in your joy
and channeling the divine works through
you and you become a miracle worker
and so i really wanted to share that it
doesn't matter if you're
a stylist doesn't matter whatever it is
that you're doing if you are
in your if you are in your joy because
joy is the highest human frequency that
we have
so when we are in a state of joy and
however way that is and for me it's play
play brings me tremendous joy and
collaboration that raises trend is joy
and um you know so when we're in that
state of joy we're in that channel and
then we get connected and then
the divine works through us so when
we're feeling like why can't i
why am i don't feel connected or why do
i because you literally aren't
you are literally separated from
yourself
yeah from your joy from your channel and
um
and there's no higher calling yeah than
to have become miracle workers
yes and do do your work the divine
working through you as an instrument as
a conduit
but if you're not synced up if you're
not linked up it can't the divine can't
get through
so that's my that's my piece my last
piece that i really really wanted to
share because that's a piece that i i
reinstall
over and over and over and over and over
and over again it's like gang into our
joy
yes
especially since i came back from that
high level perception
visual distillation that i've been
just hitting it over and over again that
tap in to that
and i use these examples these are just
the examples that i use
into the christ consciousness into the
buddha consciousness into the lao
subconsciousness the confucius level
consciousness the absolute
highest possible morality ethics
spirituality and
live from that on a daily basis
on a moment-to-moment basis and you just
butterfly effect
everything you touch is gold and
perfection at that point
if you create as an artist or an
entrepreneur from there there's
no ethical issues there's no moral
issues there's none of those
that happen and but that that that is
very very difficult
you know that's limiting belief as well
but that it takes it takes practice to
ground that to anchor that
in our soul and but that process is
so crucial and so important and the more
that we kind of
practice those ancient perennial
spiritual mystic traditions
around the planet especially those like
that where was the where was the shaman
from again that came into colombia that
was a colombian shaman
but i love that i love that so that will
that will open
that will open it up that type of you
know that's
that's the stuff and i love it i also
want to
um visually show that we have
um as you saw we have the power
priestess posse
group on facebook so there it is right
there
facebook.com four slash groups four
slash the power priestess posse
and you can also find that in the links
in the bio below
and i will also show you
the power priestess on tick tock
so that's tick tock dot com forward
slash at the power priestess
and go and check out those videos
and follow them i'm just not logged in
but i haven't followed on on my account
and
yeah and also yeah check out some you
know
you have there's a video on there that's
at there's a video on there that's at a
million views
here actually i wanna i'm gonna pull it
i wanna pull it up
i think it's really important and i
reposted it now it's at over four
hundred thousand yeah
she posted it twice so it's yeah exactly
so it's at one and a half
or so yeah it's a little further there
it is this video right here
is that uh um is that a million views
and it was reposted again has
so i mean that's no guys that's no you
we all know that's
no small feat to be able to attain that
kind of viewership
and so um it's a big deal like the like
jess's ability to compress the meme of
the divine feminine into a tik-tok video
right and then to have that succeed at
that level it's i mean i
that's only divine there's no other way
for me because i i have other videos
that i think are fantastic that i've
done and they haven't had
nearly that kind of touch and that's
okay like i'm happy that the the
transmission
is important that the transmission gets
out yeah so um
i do want to really acknowledge the
beauties of the posse there's like so
many names i like i want to like
flirt out and blast out and if i had
four more hours i would speak about
every single one and like how much
they do you know has you know all right
you want me to do yeah
all right all right okay shout out to
sella
tabitha ashley madison
kristen heather misty marie nancy
nancy oh my gosh um i'm going through
them
astra liliana isanna um
and some of the men uh nathan
david uh you greg
um oh my gosh who else tell me some more
layla oh my gosh there's so many oh
if i could just break well you can bring
it up what do you think oh is that but
is that okay
i don't know if that's okay for them no
that's true well it was more like for me
for you oh i see oh i see oh i see yeah
yeah yeah
there's so many incredible souls that
was a lot
that was already jody um
deb um kristen of course
uh you know oh my gosh there's just i
cannot
even say enough so many
oh i mean there's over 1600 i'm so pr
lisa heidi oh my gosh like
i love all the shout outs i adore the
show
they're popping up they're popping up
beautiful story in every single
one so oh yeah and there's there's again
so
so many and i i love you all and you
know
that i would i would name every single
one that
you know it's been it's been how they've
shown up too
like it's not a posse if it's just me
that's right yeah that's the synergistic
fire that's cool
it's bringing us all together so i just
i love you all so much and i'm so proud
of you and i
love your contributions and what we're
creating together in the world and i
know it's only been a couple months
and like just the transformations and
the magic and the joy
and the power and just everything that
like the deep dives that we've done it's
just it's truly truly
remarkable and i'm so proud of us all
and thank you goddesses thank you to the
goddesses so much
for for believing in us and infusing us
with so much like it's just
um absolutely
cataclysmic you know it's supernova it's
a supernova that we're having just
we're creating this huge it's a velocity
piece and it's time and i think that's
why we're all
waking up or getting geared up really
really fast so
yeah all that's happening um oh and
christine christine
thank you saving my butt um so
and and thank you to you so much
like i mean i know and
i know and like two years ago right when
i
asked you like how can i best support
you and you wrote you said to me
meet your goals and i was like
like i wanted to please you and you
never took it you constantly put it back
on me what are you
doing and like as you were hustling and
you're like what are you doing
what are what are you working on just to
do that and i felt like
like awful because like i didn't have my
thing yet
and i was like you had your thing coco
had her thing you guys had you were
direct paths and you knew exactly where
you were going and i didn't have it and
it was
absolutely agonizing agonizing to be in
that space
and feeling like i know i'm meant to do
something i know i'm being called and i
don't know what it is yet and it's not
here and i can't figure it out and like
i was
just so wracked with that you know and
so
so again like to be here in this moment
with you
where like you were at the genesis of
you are at a genesis point of many
moments for me
and likewise you know and and
we knew we were co-creators two years
ago we knew that and
so it means everything that you're to me
that you know you're here
you're my first night that i knighted
and you know
and that and how that has touched your
life you know and please tell the men
that like
i know you do i know you do but like
when they know
who they're serving like what they're in
service too
yeah you know it's kind of like in a way
you know and i wasn't in the military so
i can't say but there's a sense of duty
and honor in that
because i know who they're serving yes
you know but there's a many men who
don't know who they're serving
and they're just kind of listless and
like well i guess i'll go
chase the dollar or i guess i'll go
build this company i mean i guess that's
what i'm supposed to do like
serve the highest that's what we were
just talking about
so yeah serving the highest so again
like if you see a woman in your life
that you want to uplift
ask how you can like if she has that
magic and she hasn't had that foundation
we're trying to build temples on sand we
need like support
you know like really like hey what
what are your goals like wait wait is it
really like that complex
no like just like what are your goals
have goals how can i serve you
how can i serve you how can i support
you like that's the question we
must ask one another like yeah yeah yeah
so that's
i i'm uh
i charlie
charlie oh
[Laughter]
oh my gosh oh my gosh there's like the
next waves yeah yeah they're all okay
i thought you said jen yeah okay yeah
there's a few you did at the beginning
yeah yeah
i did you did yeah yeah entire tarly is
in a freaking amazing amazing woman and
she's
actually who created i thrive the
non-profit well that's great so tyler
reed yeah she created it
she's a powerhouse she's amazing amazing
amazing we've known each other for
several years and it's such a gift
because she created this non-profit
in preparation for something to come
that she hadn't seen yet and so she
created it
and now we're fusing it all together so
it's amazing
and that also will we be able to put
that link in the bio below there's a
link
yeah we're creating um yeah we're
creating a
paypal link and a patreon or i don't
know something where we're
yeah i thrive because whatever funds
yeah go there
directly it's going to support
wonderland so it's going to support the
world
it's going to funnel also into a
wonderland oh
interesting okay okay yeah there's a lot
more to unpack on
the next sit down on that and also more
on
just the nature of conscious and reality
in general consciousness and reality in
general so
we'll um we'll wrap um
blessed yes blessed
i have so much love for you me too i'm
so glad we're at this moment
you were you're spot on that i was i was
watching that
that that juggling of different things
of you until it really
formulated into this so it's just
i love seeing that i love seeing that
artist play their solo
you know it's awesome i love it so much
it's it's really what again i i do think
that the north star plays a
fundamental role in the nature of
reality so
all right that's a wrap
rob thank you so much thank you yeah
yeah
onward yeah answer the call answer the
call
answer the call yeah
that defined feminine that goddess i
love it i love it power priestess posse
everyone
uh check it out links in the bio below
again for the facebook group
also for the tiktok account uh and
also support the divine feminine around
you support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
in your community support them help them
flourish
maximize the potential of our entire
social fabric get the basic needs to
every single
soul to every single seed and have them
unleash their fruits of goodness
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in
and we will see you soon let us know
your thoughts in the comments below we'd
love to hear from you
come to wonderland come to wonderland
come to wonderland come to wonderland
to wonderland